boys do you know what you're playing no
no
this is the hardest mod in all of
minecraft why'd you bring
us we were playing rl craft it is known
across the community as the hardest
thing to ever exist you have to track
water you have to track
food there's dinosaurs creatures wizards
mobs
everything about this is incredibly
complex and weird what is that
i don't know go say hi to it good idea
chandler go check it out oh my gosh that
is terrifying it just gave me knowledge
knowledge thank you now die wait why'd
you hurt it
let's go into the orb going to the orb
oh my gosh
oh get away get away get away all right
don't mess with the wisp
wait jimmy yeah carl look down there i
think it's a crashed ship wait yeah but
look what i saw
up here a castle wait how'd i miss that
let's go check it out carla okay carl
what do you think is on this castle uh
i think things that are gonna hurt us
i'm not gonna lie
oh my gosh whoa you don't meet the
requirements to break this block oh
what oh oh i can't see whoa guys
go around the outskirts of the castle
yeah come on
oh wow carl something's chasing you oh
my god okay okay
one shot are you kidding me oh i almost
walked off
what oh i was pummeled by ashton
dejen oh oh there's a dinosaur
like in the last mod video where the
loser had to buy a hundred barbie dolls
was that fun channel it was great we
also have a punishment for this video
for whoever dies the most chandler
carl jimmy that's me whoever has the
most desk has to brush their teeth
and then drink a glass of orange
what's the juice combination in history
it actually is apparently chandler you
have the most deaths
and as of now you're brushing your teeth
and then oh
what oh oh oh oh oh get away get away
get away now we're tied
wow i haven't died yet what is that get
away from me
get away from me get away from me i can
hit like a fairy
get away
you have to be a level four screw your
level four
ugh
i love how in the last modded video carl
was the one to find the minecraft
girlfriend
and in this video he finds the mermaids
it's almost like women just flocked to
carl but they end up not liking him
ow i can't even spawn without dying all
right come on come on come on
what he just said a flip out of the
water what is that
oh my gosh he's right outside
wow whoa no stop stop
stop oh come on how are there more
mermaids
stop carl get out of the water i wasn't
even in the water
they stopped flirting with the mermaids
for five seconds carl come on man
oh my gosh
[Music]
don't tell carl but we're actually tied
dude i can't even get to the surface
did you die again carl are you ready yes
yes
carl real quick i have a question yeah
do you like orange juice
why do i keep spawning in the middle of
the ocean oh no
whoa i will not die on that oh what is
that
oh my god we're good we're good
just got in the water and there's ink
sacks everywhere which means
something big just killed a lot of
squids i have a spider chasing me and i
don't know what to do
oh he climbed up oh i bet he's who
killed the squids oh he's coming for me
he's coming for me oh oh
oh i'm terrified get away from me no i
thought he was a sea creature how did he
go on land
he's spawn camping how do you feel now
that's what happened to me
seven times in a row oh i'm starting to
see that dragon
he's shooting fire just randomly into
the ocean for no reason
let's take this moment to do something
special carl if you or chris what would
you say right now dude that was totally
carl's fault
dude i didn't mean to kill you dude carl
i didn't mean to kill you whenever i was
hitting you with a sword or throwing
snowballs at you
what is that don't look at me don't i
made eye contact with it i made eye
contact with it ah
ah ah what what is going on i wonder is
you're not oh my god it's a shrimp i
just got killed by a six foot shrimp oh
turkeys yeah baby
gobble baby
so darg what is that oh how about
surplus pantaloons of defense
all right is is my screen pitch black
for anyone else what's happening
i don't know what's happening i
physically can't see i
spawned in the middle of the ocean where
do i even go
carl what happened when you found a
mermaid they teleported me towards them
and then killed them
oh my gosh what is happening get away
jimmy
roll out
oh no she's chasing me
i never imagined a mermaid could be that
terrifying as of now i have 10 deaths
and chandler has 20. carl you've died 13
times
um the actual numbers are like literally
being dead serious i've died 10 times
chandler's died five times carl's down
four times so i'm
literally in last place by a lot so i've
been wandering through the ocean this
whole time
and i found this there's a chest
teleport you to your spawn point oh
what is that come on
man i wasn't even in the freaking water
yo i got a
iron dagger i have a wood sword
can you jump in water oh what the f
something just hit me midair and knocked
me out
oh i found the best island in the game
the boys have to have a meeting what's
in the chest
tell me your coordinates before you
continue oh yeah uh my coordinator
uh 1 800 screw you i don't think that's
coordinated yo
what is this wormhole portion
what'd i find hello there oh it's a
graveler i'm from pokemon
what is this what because it's so unfair
you broke my legs now i can't even swim
dude
hello friendlies oh not friendlies
no what the f throw your fast oh my gosh
no no
how all right me and your ty chandler do
you want to drink some orange juice
am i gonna drown bro oh my gosh i hear
something behind me get away from me
get away from me what the ocean yes
what he won him oh what is that
what the bird a bird just picked me up
bro what
a freaking eagle just swoop down
and grabbed me look at it or whatever
this is what
i'm literally flying in the air what oh
he dropped me
okay he just dropped me in the water he
gave me weight too dude what the heck i
went to the bathroom and i'm dead
how did i die get away get away yes get
away get away your mom
what i don't like how they just hit you
twice and you lose two hearts and then
you just die
yeah and then you get lose seven yeah
what is up with that you like
get kind of hurt and then just
completely dead what is this
what is it why why are things glowing ow
ow
ow ow i was pricked to death i died to a
cactus
the fairies aren't nice
i was about to say i was embarrassed
because i died by a dinosaur but then
you died by a cactus
oh now the bird why
i don't know what it is chandler you're
currently in last place
why don't you quit camping i'm not
camping i just spawned in the middle of
the ocean what do you want me to do
not spawn there bro i'm doing good i'm
leveling up guys are you guys proud of
me
guys five more minutes until the winner
is determined
i am currently in last place with 13.
chandler has 12 deaths congratulations
taylor
ow stop of course i got picked up by the
bird wait this dude this this bird is
camping me
it's camping waiting for me to come out
of the water oh wait wait i'm using my
recall potion
yes yes i had a spawn potion i used the
big brains they call me dream no why are
you hitting me
i have 14 deaths chandler has 12. carl
has seven
oh no my sword ran out is that snow or
creatures oh there's a there's a there's
something else in here that i didn't see
i'm sorry i don't want no i don't want
no trouble i don't want no trouble i
don't want to drink horseshoes go away
what is that is that a buchasaur
a bush saurus a bush of wrecks guys
someone fight someone besides me you
what do you have vegetarian kill them
kill them eat them you stupid giant
green glob
hey jimmy if it makes you feel better
i'm still winning i feel like i'm safe
to just die as much as i want now
oh oh come on man
they're just like out of nowhere how is
my sword almost out i've used it three
times
go away go away i see you coming no
stop stop you're
not hiding up level stop it's not fair
it's not fair i was planning on killing
you but i'm not a high note level yes
i have a god apple i had
like six hearts and you just want him
hey that shrimp looked deadly i ain't
messing with it
yeah dude jimmy got killed by a shrimp
already yo is this ikea tower
psych i actually watch pewdiepie i know
there's 30 seconds left but i don't even
think there's a need to wait
guys the challenge is officially over i
have 16 deaths
chandler has 20 deaths and carl has 14.
i don't think that's the right number i
definitely only died
13 times all right he called me on my
blog i came in last place
with 16 dabs which means i have to drink
orange juice
after brushing my teeth yes all right
all right
hold my toothbrush
it tastes like mint orange juice i don't
think you're talking drink it's a good
description i did it i hate you i hate
you
i don't hate you subscribe goodbye